by now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week according
to the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention
cigarette smoking takes the lives of
more than four hundred eighty thousand
Americans every year trying to prevent
people from taking up the habit is a key
focus in public health
on Thursday the Food and Drug
Administration said the agency will
continue to explore one potential
solution regulating nicotine levels in
cigarettes to make them less addictive
though we are a long way from that
becoming policy joining us from our
Washington bureau to discuss this is CBS
News medical contributor dr. David agus
doc good morning morning Alex morning
Anthony so let's talk first about this
potential regulation what are the
implications if it actually does become
policy you always say the word if so in
2009 the FDA was given authority to
control tobacco and this has been
something that's been talked about for
several years that is lowering the
nicotine level which is the addictive
component in tobacco it's been going up
over decades and the idea is if you can
lower the nicotine level in tobacco
there'll be less addiction and people
will hopefully smoke less there was
actually a study several years ago
showing that if you lowered nicotine and
cigarettes people smoked fewer
cigarettes how and that was a study in
the New England Journal of Medicine
David I think you're referring to how
significant a reduction do you get it's
a pretty significant reduction and so
the estimates actually are in this
current issue of New England Journal of
Medicine is that if you lower nicotine
and tobacco in about a year you're gonna
get five million fewer smokers that's a
staggering number well and so if we take
away the addictive component people are
gonna want to smoke less especially
young people once they get hooked in the
addictive nicotine they keep on it so if
we can keep that low we can have an
impact a big one on public health Doc's
some people's are using e-cigarettes to
help them get off regular cigarettes
what does the research say about whether
or not that's a good idea I think the
research says very simply the jury's
still out these cigarettes are a
delivery vehicle for nicotine is
nicotine goes on a carrier molecule
which gets it into the lung the effect
of that carrier
in the lung really isn't known yet and
so alternatives I like the concept but
we still need the data to show that
e-cigarettes are safe okay our next
topic deals with the financial burden of
cancer it was an issue address this week
in a new report by the president's
cancer panel the focus was on the price
of cancer drugs especially recently
developed medications in part of the
panel's public letter to the president
they wrote the challenge at hand is
complex innovative drugs offer new hope
for patients to achieve long term
remissions even cures but virtually all
new cancer drugs enter the market with a
price tag that exceeds a 100 thousand
dollars per year what were some of the
key recommendations here dr. agus well
this is a problem right every new cancer
drug is a hundred to two hundred
thousand dollars and so they have a
monopoly in a sense they're the only one
to treat a certain stage of a certain
disease and so it's predatory practice
and so this committee said listen we
have to stop this it's not sustainable
let's figure out a way to praise the
price drugs based on value so the drugs
that have few side effects and work
really well probably deserve a higher
price tag whereas the ones that cause
lots of side effects or don't work as
well don't and let's figure out a value
system for the patient and the system
where we can have a logical pricing of
drugs that's really interesting the
report showed some also showed some
interesting data when it comes to the
launch of new cancer drugs in comparison
to income what exactly did it show I
that was a somewhat depressing figure in
the paper where they had income totally
flat and they had the price of cancer
drugs at launch go up like this and so
when incomes not changing and every year
drugs are getting more expensive you
know it's not going to have to be
sustainable going forward it's not right
job there is also news about over
payment for prescription drugs what can
you tell us about that that's the
wildest study coming out of University
of Southern California what they showed
is is that let's say you go and you go
to get a medicine for your asthma and
they say their copay is twenty dollars
well many times in fact in the study 23%
of the time the copay was more than the
drug costs on a generic basis
and the pharmacies in the country have a
gag order from the pharmaceutical
Bennett Matt a benefit manager then they
can't tell you that listen if you say
I'm gonna pay cash it'll be seven bucks
but paying with insurance it's 20 bucks
because you have that copay so something
is wrong in that system that gag order
makes no sense yeah it certainly makes
no sense sounds like some reforms are
needed dr. David agus thank you as
always for rising early and giving us
the good word on health and medicine